there's no words Chris Appleton's the
best
we heard it from Northwest
steps out with her mama Kim Kardashian
and drops the mic I don't know what's
gonna top that the mommy-daughter duo
attended the daily front Rose seventh
annual fashion Los Angeles Awards on
Sunday looking Chic as ever Kim in a
gray Rick Owens Bando top with matching
wrap midi skirt paired with silver heels
and a vintage Dior necklace yeah Bible
it's a great look North in a black Dolce
and Gabbana suit and you guessed it
skim's t-shirt the two posed alongside
the man responsible for Kim's Tresses
Chris Appleton and later presented him
with the hair artist of the year award
North took the mic first stealing the
spotlight with a simple but bold intro
there's no words Chris Appleton's the
best
as for Kim she elaborated on all that
sharing some sweet words about her pal
it's not really that often when someone
comes into your life and changes it in
such a major special way and Chris
Appleton is just that for me it was
quite a weekend for Chris the cute on
stage moment came just hours after he
tied the knot with Lucas Gage on
Saturday in Vegas
but back to north thank you earlier this
month the nine-year-old was living her
pre-teenage dream joining Katy Perry on
stage at the singer's Vegas residency
show
[Music]
[Applause]
Kim surprised her daughter and a few of
her Pals with tickets to the concert we
have our Katy Perry mocktails and
naturally she documented the whole thing
on social media
[Music]
[Applause]
North did what North does and dropped
the mic again what do you want to be
when you grow up uh everything
yeah she said everything people it's
really fun to see of course it's no
secret that North is super talented Kim
previously showed off these portraits
her daughter sketched of North's younger
bro Psalm and Grandma Kris Jenner oh my
gosh such a gift and last year North
showed off her vocal chops singing
alongside Sia at the Kardashian family
Christmas party
[Music]
over on Tick Tock North's proven she's
got makeup skills too transforming into
her famous dad Kanye West
[Music]
and turning her mom into the Grinch
You're a mean one
Mr Grinch and a minion
she definitely loves makeup she loves a
before and after so whether she's
delivering an epic one-liner there's no
words Chris Appleton's the best or
bringing us grade A content on tick tock
North sure knows how to deliver a moment
[Music]
foreign